lors de votre journal de l'afrique soyez
les bienvenus à la une de l'actualité
sénégal qui file en finale de la can les
lions de la teranga se sont imposés ce
soir face au burkina faso benoît
perreault chez nous attend à yaoundé
liman dao nous fera vivre lui les toutes
premières réactions à dakar
à la une également ce massacre dans un
camp de déplacés en ituri à l'est de la
république démocratique du congo plus de
50 personnes assassinées des femmes et
des enfants pour la plupart une milice
communautaire est soupçonné le
gouvernement parle de crimes contre
l'humanité
et puis à vis à aux larmes et en actions
l'état major tentent d'identifier les
commanditaires de la so d'hier onze
personnes ont été tuées le mobile n'est
pas connu le président mba l'eau accuse
les réseaux de drogue
ils avaient les crocs les lions de la
teranga 3 buts à 1 face aux étalons du
burkina faso la place en finale est donc
assurée pour le sénégal vont soir avant
peignoir et rocher vous êtes lent et
spécial de france 24 à yaoundé vous avez
évidemment suivi cette rencontre ce duel
choc même et benoît le sénégal rêve de
la soulever enfin cette coupe il s'en
approche
eh bien oui il s'en approche comme en
2019 ou là aussi s'était qualifié pour
la finale en egypte avant de céder face
à l'algérie je vous rappelle que le
sénégal ne compte aucun titre à son
palmarès qui peut sembler évidemment à
une anomalie de l'histoire étant donné
la qualité de l'effectif du sénégal les
lions de la teranga qui sont donc venus
à bout ce soir de cette vaillante de
cette courageuse équipe du burkina faso
dans une demi finale est très fermé avec
beaucoup d'engagement physique des deux
côtés surtout en première période on va
retenir la sortie sur blessure du
gardien des étalons rdquo fille après un
contact avec kouyaté 45 premières
minutes où l'arbitré a accordé deux
penalties aux sénégalais avant de se
raviser et avec raison et on peut le
salut et larbi plus qu'il a été
courageuse et pas toujours le cas d'un
arbitre quitte à les consulter la var et
qui est donc revenu à chaque fois sur
ses décisions tout va se jouer
finalement en deuxième période des
sénégalais de retour des vestiaires
beaucoup plus trop chan dans leur course
avec beaucoup plus de vivacité des
joueurs qui ont combiné entre pour
donner plus de rythme l'ouverture du
score du joueur du psg abdou diallo
suivi de son coéquipier du paris
saint-germain idrissa gueye pour le 2 à
0 réduction du score dans la foulée des
étalons finalement le sénégal qui va se
mettre définitivement à l'abri à la 87e
minute je vous le donne en mille par
l'inévitable évidemment le meilleur
joueur dont on parle tous sadio man et
l'attaquant de liverpool encore une fois
époustouflant ce soir donc il a inscrit
ce troisième but mais il avait également
adressé la passe décisive pour gagner
sur le deuxième but le sénégal qui a
désormais rendez vous dimanche avec la
finale ce sera au stade paul mba et ils
connaîtront leur adversaire demain le
pays hôte le cameroun où l'egypte merci
beaucoup benoît on a revécu les temps
forts de ce match avec vous retrouve
maintenant direct depuis dakar et limane
dao bon saura vous aider à voir on
l'entend je crois pour longtemps même
cette ferveur cette liesse dans les rues
de la capitale sénégalaise l'équipe
nationale est acclamé en imaginant
et puis écoutez j'ai du mal à vous
entendre mais l'ambiance est
indescriptible actuellement sur la place
de l'indépendance derrière moi vous
pouvez voir les scènes de liesse les
sénégalais sont heureux très contents de
cette victoire les célébrations se
poursuivent depuis le coup de sifflet
final
un jeune vient enfin garçons comme tout
le monde est sorti dans la rue
s'élèverait à cette victoire du sénégal
concert de vuvuzelas et à des supporters
très très très heureux vous pouvez voir
dernièrement autour de moi ils sont
entrés de toujours celles
attendait certes assez les sidéens il a
fallu attendre la deuxième mi temps
[Musique]
mais l'essentiel du message est passé
dakar en fait absolument pas car en fait
jamais trop sûr tout n'est pas
complètement joué encore
merci elimane et merci beaucoup aux
supporters
et puis sachez que le match pour la
troisième place sur le podium se jouera
finalement ce samedi 5 février à 20h à
yaoundé pas dimanche comme prévu
initialement c'est la caf qu'il a
annoncé la rencontre est avancé pour ne
pas empiéter sur la finale jouée au
stade au lait mais justement
dans l'actualité de ce mercredi aussi ce
massacre en ituri dans le nord-est de la
république démocratique du congo plus de
50 personnes y ont été tuées à l'armé
blanche et des femmes et des enfants
pour la plupart leur vie s'est arrêtée
dans un campement de fortune un site
pour déplacer milices communautaire est
pointé du doigt la correspondance de
clément benoît
selon la société civile locale la taxe
est produite aux environs d'une heure du
matin mercredi un groupe de miliciens a
pris d'assaut le camp de savo près de la
ville de boules et munis de machettes et
d'armes à feu l'armée congolaise a donné
mercredi un bilan provisoire de 21 morts
mais la société civile ainsi que le
conseil norvégien pour les réfugiés
parlent d'environ 60 personnes tuées
dont une majorité de femmes et d'enfants
le camp abritait plus de 24 mille
personnes déplacées les miliciens de la
codeco la coopérative pour le
développement du congo sont un pointé du
doigt il s'agit d'un ensemble de milice
de la communauté lendou qui mènent
régulièrement des attaques à la fois
contre les forces gouvernementales mais
aussi contre des membres de la
communauté emma les deux communautés se
sont affrontés notamment entre 1999 et
2003 forçant à l'intervention d'une
force de maintien de la paix de l'union
européenne et les violences ont repris
depuis 2010 est et depuis les attaques
décoder qu on fait des centaines de
morts et provoqué le déplacement de plus
d'un million et demi de personnes et les
camps de déplacés sont particulièrement
visés au moins 68 personnes ont perdu la
vie au cours d' attaques contre 5 caen
est différent dans la même note depuis
novembre
dans la capitale à l'ouest de kinshasa
un câble électrique s'est effondré sur
le marché matadi kibala une partie du
fils est tombé dans un caniveau rempli
d'au moins 26 personnes sont mortes par
électrocution selon porte-parole du
gouvernement provincial une enquête est
ouverte pour établir des responsabilités
laurent berst cher et juliette du bois
revient en images sur les faits
au milieu des piles de déchets et de
légumes le câble restait tendue dans
l'eau sale du marché de matadi kibala le
même câble qui quelques heures
auparavant avait répandu la décharge
électrique meurtrière coûtant la vie à
au moins 26 personnes chez les habitants
du quartier le deuil était teintée de
colère car le drame aurait pu être évité
urbanistique à deux quand ce ne sont pas
respectées en de cet espace vide avant
cet incident j'étais en train dé déploré
le fait on craignait que les piles
arriver aujourd'hui malheureusement les
pelles est arrivée en rdc il est
interdit de construire à moins de 30
mètres d'un pylônes haute tension mais
ces normes sont rarement respectées
comme dans ce marché de l'ouest de
kinshasa où les états les habitations de
fortune jouxte le pylône en métal des
amas de déchets y bouge aussi les
caniveaux entraînant des inondations
fréquentes au marché où les vendeurs ont
pris l'habitude de travailler les pieds
dans l'eau les autorités congolaises qui
ont annoncé l'ouverture d'une enquête
pour établir les responsabilités de
l'incident disent vouloir prendre des
mesures pour sécuriser le quartier on va
les pousser le marché à l'intérieur et
voir dans quelle mesure
évacué là pour toute la population qui
habite les bat del à haute tension selon
la société nationale d'électricité
congolaise un orage serait à l'origine
de l'accident mais plusieurs habitants
dénoncent des câbles mal installés et
mal entretenus et des autorités qui ont
trop longtemps ignoré leurs
avertissements
une vaste opération lancée ce mercredi à
bissau en guinée l'armée tentent
d'identifier les commanditaires de la
tentative de coup d'état des recherches
sont également menées au siège du
gouvernement le président mba l'eau fait
but de lier entre les assaillants et le
narcotrafic onze personnes au moins ont
été tuées le récit christophe danse est
un sourire pour rassurer après plusieurs
heures de confusion
et cette image le président umaru
sissoko malo entouré de son premier
ministre bonne santé
tout commence en début d'après midi des
tirs nourris retentissent tout près du
palais du gouvernement où tous les
responsables politiques du pays sont
réunis le président lui est exfiltré
ce n'était pas ça l'objectif de la lutte
pour la libération nous nous sommes
battus pour que le pays puisse avancer
comment se fait-il que d'autres pays
aient volume et que nous continuons à
nous battre à quoi ça sert
hier j'ai pris mes jambes à mon cou
quand j'ai entendu les coups de feu j'ai
vraiment couru longtemps
les jeunes doivent arrêter de faire ce
genre de choses
je veux que cela cesse une bonne fois
pour toutes
le président les films qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un coup d'état politique ce ne
sont pas seulement les militaires qui
sont impliqués mais c'est surtout la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue qui en
est à l'origine parce que la plupart des
personnes impliquées sont des personnes
inscrites sur la liste d' enquête anti
drogue la guinée-bissau a longtemps été
considérée comme l'une des plaques
tournantes du narcotrafic en afrique la
porte d'entrée des cargaisons de drogue
venue d'amérique du sud une page
désormais tournée affirmé le président
mba l'eau sur notre antenne en octobre
dernier
l'onu l'union africaine et la cedeao
condamne une tentative de coup d'état à
l'image de ce communiqué
l'allemagne s'interroge sur la poursuite
de son engagement au mali ce 1500
soldats ils sont déployés selon berlin
dispositif militaire européen doit être
réévalué les autorités françaises se
donne le temps de la réflexion h rennes
verte ya
deux jours après l'annoncé de
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur français au
mali paris s'interroge sur l'avenir de
sa présence militaire sur place il ya
une rupture politique dans la mesure où
si ce pays est dirigé maintenant par une
junte autoproclamé et qui estiment ne
pas pouvoir engager un processus
démocratique avant 5 ans et rupture
aussi de ce pays de la junte au pouvoir
avec la communauté internationale avec
les nations unies avec les pays voisins
puis rupture militaire parce que de plus
en plus il ya des entraves à notre
fonctionnement fin 2021 les autorités
maliennes issu d'un double putsch disent
vouloir rester en place potentiellement
cinq années supplémentaires
décision contraire à leur engagement
initial d'organiser des élections fin
février 2022
inacceptable pour la cedeao qui prend
des sanctions contre le mali bamako
estime que paris est derrière cette
décision depuis les tensions ne cessent
de s'accentuer une détérioration qui
concerne aussi les partenaires européens
de la france engagée au mali on sait que
maintenant pour faire voler leurs drones
et leurs hélicos les allemands ont
besoin d'un d'un accord d'un préavis de
30 6 heures on sait que bamako a demandé
aux danois de partir qui sont partis les
norvégiens aujourd'hui on dit qu'ils
n'allaient plus envoyés de force vers
vers le mali comme la france l'allemagne
juge elle aussi que l'engagement des
européens au mali doit désormais être
réévalués
nous nous félicitons des efforts
déployés par l'onu pour inciter le
gouvernement intérimaire malien à rendre
le pouvoir aux civils
si cela ne marche pas nous devrons
évidemment réévaluer notre présence sur
place mais d'ici là nous restons en
stand by
pour l'heure la france a entamé un re
déploiement de ses forces au sahel de
5000 aujourd'hui ces soldats seront 2500
2023 un désengagement progressif qui
intervient parallèlement à l'expansion
de la présence russe dans la région via
les paramilitaires de la société privée
wagner présente entre autres au mali
et puis sachez que la ministre française
désarmé et florence parly se rendra ce
jeudi au niger à ouagadougou la reprise
du procès des assassins présumés de
thomas sankara la constitution est
rétabli les débats peuvent donc
reprendre ils avaient été suspendus il
ya deux jours elle l'audience de ce
mercredi était dédiée aux parties
civiles la parole leur a été donné à 12
personnes ont pris place dans le box des
accusés et dizaine d'autres suspects
comparaissent également mais pas
l'ancien président blaise compaore
ainsi s'achève votre journal de
l'afrique merci à vous d'avoir suivi cet
avis que nous sur france24 l'information
continue
[Musique]